[Applause]
all right what's happening right now is
Biden's weakness on the world stage has
never been more apparent but Republican
leaders thankfully are pushing back
against our adversaries now yesterday
South Dakota Governor Christie gnome
signed a bill Banning China and other
quote evil foreign governments from
State contracts and today Tick Tock CEO
was grilled by lawmakers on Capitol Hill
over concerns that the social media
company is spying on Americans take a
look
do you disagree with FBI director Ray
and NSA director nicosone when they said
that the CCP could have the capability
to manipulate data and send it to the
United States do you disagree with their
statement their statement says could so
do you disagree with that
no I don't disagree with that okay has
fight dance spied on American citizens I
don't think that spying is the right way
to describe it
gnome is with us Governor how are you
we got a great crowd that wishes you
were here
all right it sounds like it so you were
the first one of the first Governors to
say no to tick tock now you have banned
China and uh other evil foreign
governments from State contracts
um and you mentioned them you know China
Cuba Iran Korea Russia Venezuela thank
God you're doing that thank God you're
leading on this front I wish every
Governor will follow suit
well it's been wonderful to see some of
them take action after we did we were
the state that first brought the ban of
tick tock on state devices and on our
servers we made it a criminal offense if
a state employee or someone did download
or access it from one of our devices and
jeopardize people's personal information
over 30 States took action after we did
here in South Dakota and then we saw
Congress as well ban it for federal
devices as well it's been great to see
them hold hearings finally and to be
talking about this important issue
recognize that the Chinese Communist
party will put its people through hell
in order to keep them in bondage I hope
the American people are willing to be
just a little bit inconvenienced to
protect their freedom because that's
really what this is about it's about
giving up yeah
it's about giving up an app to not allow
our enemies to spy on us and manipulate
our children and to use algorithms to
influence us it's incredibly important
that we take action like this I'm so
grateful that other states are taking
action and the federal government as
well well could you maybe call Joe Biden
and tell him the next time a Chinese spy
balloon flies over our entire country
yes maybe they should shoot it down uh
before it gets over Alaska airspace
because you know they got away with that
and then he let Putin get away with
taking down one of our drones now uh to
me that's nothing but a sign of weakness
and that will incur further aggression
we see President XI President Putin
basically hugging and kissing each other
they're now in love it seemed like a
romance is now Brewing but it's a danger
to the world isn't it
oh absolutely and that's why you see
Governors taking action that's why I
brought an executive order months ago to
ban State contracts and
telecommunication contacts within the
state that's we got that codified into
law signed it yesterday that now uh no
evil foreign government will be able to
gain revenue from business with the
state of South Dakota help other states
will follow that as well and I brought
legislation that would keep China from
buying our land here so I'm hopeful that
we'll continue to see progress on that
listen the only reason that we feel like
we have to be so aggressive is because
our federal government our president are
failing they are endangering the
American people they are weak and so
Governors have a responsibility a duty
to protect our people and that's why you
see us getting so engaged on these
foreign policy issues your name Governor
comes up in terms of a possible
candidate for 2024 have you considered
that are you considering that
oh I tell you what I am considering
going to bed in a few hours when I get
done with all my work today so I you
gotta there's a lot to do
I'll hear we're just grateful that
you're willing to chat with us once in a
while Sean if that wasn't so funny I
would really be mad you didn't answer
the question but um is there any any
consideration at all
you know listen I think we really need a
president in this country that doesn't
wake up every day dreaming of being
president
um I want somebody who recognizes the
responsibility of the job how important
it is right now to do it for the right
reasons we need a different present than
the one that we've got and I think that
we've got to get the Right leader in
this country so we all get the chance to
wake up safe tomorrow morning all right
so I'll take I'll take that as
you would consider if somebody asked you
to be VP I'm just guessing but anyway
honestly uh Governor thank you thanks
for what you're doing thanks for your
leadership on this we appreciate it
thanks for being here hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else